Okay, now I just email that to Dr. Woo...
and...
Boom!
Done!
I wonder if they'll find any genetic disorders...
Hey gang, Trace here for DNews with the latest
research on human photography.
Looking for scientific data in photos has
exploded.
Analyzing medical images is big business.
Back in 2012 researchers at MIT's Computer
Science and Artificial Intelligence Lab[a]
were able to use images of the brain and computer
analysis to track how disorders like schizophrenia
originate and spread through our grey matter.
The network of cells and connections INSIDE
the brain is slowly being decoded and analyzed.
But to get this procedure you have to go get
your brain scanned a few times...
Not something you can do with that telephone
in your pocket.
Humans take a lot of pictures, especially
with the introduction of digital photography
-- according to 1000 Memories, humankind has
taken 3.5 trillion photos since 1826, but
MOST of those have been digital.
We take more photos every minute than were
taken in the whole 19th century[b], and 3
to 5 percent of all photos taken are selfies[c].
A neuroscientist from the University College
London believes we love taking selfies because
we can't see our own face!
We're learning to move it the way we want,
and show the best version of ourselves.
Scientists at Oxford created a computer which
can explore the millions of images we create
and look for people with Down's syndrome,
fragile X syndrome, and progeria.
These rare genetic disorders might be overlooked
by a human doctor, but not Doogie...
It doesn't have a name, but I think it should
be called Doogie.
This guy uses facial recognition software
to identify 36 feature points of interest
across the face -- called the facial gestalt.
The team identified the parts of the face
and then diagnosed a disorder.
It got it right 93-percent of the time.
As of this month Doogie knows 90 diseases
and the more faces it learns, the better it
gets at diagnosing.
There are 7000 different inherited disorders,
and most go undiagnosed.
But, if this system could send an email to
your doctor narrowing down the expensive and
time-consuming trial and error process of
diagnosing some of these rare disorders.
Hooking something like this into a system
with a lot of photos could be a game-changer
for people with these hidden disorders!
The Library of Congress (largest library on
the planet) has about 13.7 million photos,
that's pretty good.
But Facebook has 10,000 times more; their
library is 140 billion photos and growing
FAST.
As the internet spreads to more and more people
and selfies run amok, the data humanity is
creating could potentially give a snapshot
of what is happening economically, socially,
politically, healthily ,and maybe other -allys
too!
These are potential mines of scientific data.
The selfie future's so bright, I gotta wear
shades.
Worried about privacy?
Excited for the data?
I'm totally okay with it, but I stand here
every day, so my experience is a little different.
Tell us down below and thanks for watching
DNews!
Subscribe for more, every day of the week
aaand as long as you're in a subscribing mood.
Come check out our new sister show, Test Tube.
We cover world events, trends and actual like...
news -- mixed with a bit
of humor.
Hit the subscribe now and get that show in
your inbox the same way you're getting Dnews.
Thanks for tuning in!
Come say, "Hi," on Twitter!
We're at-DNews, and I'm at-TraceDominguez